[Applaudissements]
cinq mois après le pic de la crise
sanitaire les revendications demeurent
les mêmes pour les personnels
hospitaliers de l'hexagone et le ségur
de la santé n'a fait au mieux qu attiser
la colère dans leurs rangs de la
frustration
c'est ce qui devrait ressortir des
revendications affichées ce jeudi pour
la plupart des métiers du secteur
hospitalier
rien n'a changé depuis cet été on est
solidaires car c'est pire qu'avant le
ségur de la santé
non seulement les promesses n'ont pas
été tenues non seulement le segura
oublié plein de gens dont nous mais en
terme d'organisation des soins on n'a
pas tiré les leçons de la première vague
de co vide
on n'a même pas été invité aux c'est dur
pourtant il ya beaucoup à dire sur les
cent vingt mille infirmières libérales
partis la fleur au fusil au printemps
pour prendre en charge les patients sans
masque sans protection
moins de trois mois se sont écoulés
depuis les conclusions du ségur de la
santé et rien ne semble se concrétiser
un constat amer qui semble partagé par
tous les secteurs de l'hôpital
cette grève du 15 octobre à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale doit avant tout
permettre de pointer le manque
d'effectif mais aussi des salaires
toujours peu élevés ou encore la
suppression de trois mille quatre cents
lits en 2019
on ne peut pas dire que la situation a
évolué tant à l'hôpital que dans les
établissements de l'action sociale
la première revendication des salariés
de ces différents secteurs était
d'obtenir plus de moyens humains
or malgré les belles paroles au début de
la crise et les promesses
force est de constater qu'il n'ya rien
aucun recrutement des moyens humains
restent les mêmes une colère également
partagé par les médecins de ville en
cause des tarifs bloqué depuis 2010 est
qui font l'objet de discussions avec
l'assurance maladie
les offres de revalorisation sont jugées
ridicules par les syndicats du côté du
gouvernement on réclame de la patience
tout ne se règle pas d'un coup de
baguette magique indique-t-on au cabinet
d'olivier ferrand mais les décisions
prises tarde à se concrétiser
à l'aube de la deuxième vague du coc
vide 19 le personnel hospitalier espère
lui enfant obtenir des avancées
concrètes